guys are you sick of people talking
about the last Jedi oh boy me too it's
months in solos around the corner and
we're still talking about this movie
that's a success in its own right is it
not John oh that's yes well you want
your name in people's mouths gee maybe
this will be the last time we talked
about the last Chetta
you know what when screen junkies isn't
honest trailers for the last Jedi you
gotta check it out they have opinions on
it required viewing
speaking of which patron the day
shout-out for none other than our
Australian gentleman Kent McKnight Kent
because we know he loved the last job
very much very enthusiastic
you ready Jay I'm always ready G can't
wait to see Jenna nervous about this in
a polarized world the next installment
of the franchise all about balance and
non-attachment
will be worshipped hated and obsessed
over until it's not even fun to talk
about anymore yeah the force awakens
because episode 8 subverts everything
you've come to expect and the worst one
ever
the original honest trailer voice back
are you really gonna do the over there /
new ones are better thing we did with
the force awakens the only way to talk
about Star Wars now is in absolutes
so yes kind of city of you but fine a
refreshing update to a predictable
formula that spits in the face
[Laughter]
Rhodes coming into their own like Ray
who actor being called by Luke's
lightsaber is called by the Jedi texts
called by a big wet hole and called by
her greatest frenemy yet still gets zero
answers to any of her questions Oh gross
from a hotshot sexy pilot to a
treasonous failure with more blood on
his hands than the empire first order
Prince and fed the width of a deserter
running away from the war to a deserter
running away from the war with the
helpless newcomer rose he'll learn to
put the greater good above himself
thanks to a pointless side quests to
casino royale' because they spent 15
minutes connecting the action to a
larger thing the larger theme game is it
possible to miss pod racing I didn't
think so
but here we are but forget about the
butthurt fanboys who were just mad that
movie is a closeout of the one they
wrote in their heads neighbors like Leia
a battle-hardened general trying to keep
the spark of hope and she's in a coma
Chewbacca to do and Luke Skywalker who
after sad old Han and sad old Leia
really drives home how your heroes are
all sad and old now he's turned his back
on the franchise after watching the
prequels away like it was some kind of
joke and Star Wars is not a joke to me
you have anything to talk to you about
Rian Johnson ruined my childhood like
you doing the laws of space battle there
are faced battle there should be Luke is
it the only Skywalker who has issues
with the franchise kylo Ren is back and
he's demanding Oh
reboot watches eat defense my we live on
that we act the money duck mask
and his shirt you distracted me on
purpose
Dule moving on get ready and unexpected
answers to the puzzles of episode 7 that
can only be answered by asking what are
the most disappointing answers to the
puzzles of episode said but who are
raised parents nobody know some dead guy
and how did da stenotic it looks
lightsaber it doesn't matter and you're
stupid for asking the hours of
speculation and analysis was genuinely a
celebrating each other yeah we're both
pretty big Star Wars nerds huh so gear
up for the most divisive Star Wars film
ever made
we're Rian Johnson either doesn't
understand the more or you made the
first Star Wars movie that lives up to
the values it preaches instead of
endorsing Royal bloodlines and reckless
aggression
okay enough division let's say our
favorite things about it on the count of
three one two wait really
yeah I'll own it okay now thanks
favorite not telling any wonder why I
get it now I can fold down a peg but
come on they're taking shuttles to a
fort
why make everyone think they're gonna
die again argue that should we do this
again for solo
[Music]
[Laughter]
the brain Chi suits you we in a door
test you redemption for Star Wars kid it
is time for my fandom to end
did you hear jayjay finish the script
webisode 9 my fandom is back o the Box
in the right to watch us make F into an
egg play with puppies what the cost
rockin my mortal enemy the inner
machinations of my mind are an enigma
the first Jedi Temple
wasn't stable hers Nebraska well yeah
they've covered everything we've talked
about that you've talked about with all
your friends all the arguments all the
arguments say they did it all and that's
why I really love this honest trailer
because they got back the og I'm pretty
sure that is the actual og voice voice
the honest trailer I like the approach
of having both arguments presented at
once in this honest trailer because I'm
sure everyone just expected this
austerity come in and just tear this
movie a new one yeah so they do that
while also saying well here's what's
good like having both arguments
presented because this film is so
divisive that this was a really
interesting take for them to do an
honest trailer well it highlights the
fact that it's divisive because it made
specific choices yeah things some of
which were pretty good and some of which
are pretty bad and I love that they came
together at the end did the say your
favorite your leave at the same time
yeah the things that we're all in unison
on but and also the things that were
like well how do you feel about this how
do you feel about that cuz there's so
many things that I've loved that people
hate this was just a really cool and
unique approach I really like how honest
others have been mixing it up a lot you
know like that
out there every Western dersen movie on
a [ __ ] last week and then they do
this where they have to honors trailer
voices coming in and presenting both
arguments which can makes it the
ultimate honest trailer because for a
film like this you kind of have to
present both sides of the argument
because of how divisive it and how huge
it is and yeah I feel like they have
been stepping up because they've always
had good points on this show but I feel
like the last couple I've seen
especially I've been like pretty solid
breakdowns of these movies like film
school stuff yeah yeah and I appreciate
them for that you get your you little
education while you're laughing your
your buns off Kent McKnight gotta give
you a shout-out here buddy because I
remember when we talked about the last
Jedi you were like man this is the best
movie ever you said no I he hated the
hell out of this film fam he's
definitely old voice on his trailer a
guy when it comes to this movie man but
Kent you know what I think the problem
is is you're just not open to having a
heart full of love it sounds like to me
that you just want her to fit in with
the cool group because that's the total
vibe you give off think for yourself
being cool you just gotta think for
yourself for a change
stop just take you to everyone else's
opinions yeah take our opinion you're
Australian man quit trying to sound like
every whiny American out here dude it's
not cool to be that we'd like you for
your humble spear you like that new Star
Trek show you could like the last Jedi
too it's okay don't be embarrassed
all right we got your back I'm sorry I
just hate it when people disagree with
me
I think of films are objective and
people can't possibly truly disagree
with you they're just in denial that's
the vibe Ken really gives off I think
what you need is therapy cat Star Wars
therapy this is what the last Jedi has
taught me that everyone who doesn't like
it especially you just needs to go to
therapy they're seriously emotionally
disturbed and there's there's work you
can do because everyone who goes to
therapy is more open-minded to the last
Jedi so get some counseling and maybe
we'll give you another shout out to make
up for this weird ass one down the road
now you can have your own opinion we
will see you on the Google hangout this
week buddy you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification about
again note if I want a video ours is up
we'll catch you on the flippety-flip
ative flip